meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren kontakt hier am
sonntag ich habe ein letztes mal gesagt
wenn der kontakt nicht fassen am sonntag
kommt dann werde ich nackt eine rutsche
runter rutschen das hochladen aber er
kommt passend am sonntag außer youtube
sagt jetzt neville laden das nip tuck
tuck seite ich hab mal wieder bei
facebook gepostet was ihr denn haben
wollte und da kam dabei raus dass ich
eure kommentare kommentieren soll das
habe ich alles schon mal gesagt dass es
wahrscheinlich machen werde deswegen
habe ich bei meiner facebook-seite
gefragt was ihr denn für fragen an mich
habt was ihr für aussagen hab dich
kommentieren soll und es kam nahezu nur
geile fragen eigentlich an also erst mal
daumen hoch an euch community daumen
hoch
jedenfalls habe ich jetzt 15 fragen
einfach rausgesucht die mir da unter dem
post geschrieben wurden facebook link
und instagram und die ganze scheiße die
ich besitze besitze er gönnt mir nicht
auf reiss profile bescheißen aber den
halt alles in der beschreibung da könnt
ihr von mir folgen licon dabei sein
google+ ihren das heißt agieren weil sie
dich jedenfalls würde ich sagen es geht
los mit euren kommentaren 15 stück sind
dabei und ja wie finden jetzt orf dass
minecraft anna für die ps3 rausgekommen
ewr valentin ich finde das eigentlich
ganz gut ich fand's am anfang ein
bisschen traurig dass es erst mal nur
für die xbox rauskamen aber das ist ja
in letzter zeit allgemein irgendwie so
dass sehr viele sachen oder sehr viele
unternehmen sehr viele spiele
unternehmen die verträge mit dem mit
microsoft haben kommt mir zumindest so
vor weil warum sonst würde zum beispiel
nur fifa für die xbox man irgendwie so
ein extra pack ausbringen zu neuen
spielern und neun stadien oder so nicht
für die playstation
ich glaube das ist dass ich habe komisch
luft eingeatmet weil ich halt immer
relativ schnell und in einem pegel reden
muss wegen der aufnahme das egal
ich glaube das liegt einfach daran dass
microsoft schon vorher wussten vor dem
release der xbox wollen dass die sich
nicht so nicht annähernd so gut verkauft
wie die ps4 wie es ihr dennoch die
realität gezeigt hat der markt hat dass
er als super geregelt dass die ps4 auf
jeden fall bessere konsole finde ich auf
jeden fall
und dann hat microsoft ein paar verträge
ab gemacht und ich denke auch unter
anderem mit
minecraft damals würde ich grob sagen
weil oder so lag halt einfach anders
mojang das irgendwie nicht programmiert
kriegt dafür die playstation aber ich
habe keine ahnung aber ich finde auf
jeden fall cool das ist jetzt für die
ps3 draußen ist ich weiß es mir kaufen
werde
aber ihr könnt ihr mal schreiben ob ihr
dann von jeder eventuell video haben
wollt wo ich playstation auf der
minecraft spiele minecraft auf der
playstation passen die details von einem
neuen pc alte rahmen graka und
verbreitert was sind die daten von
meinem pc alter ich weiß gar nicht genau
was ich habe ja nie weg war ich ja 500
gigabyte windows für aufnehmen und
bearbeitung und skypen und so was alles
so halt einfach aufnehmen youtube und
dann habe ich ja noch apple drauf also
mac os x- leiden leopard keine
artgenossen oleo partners glaube ich wo
ich halt so was mache wie referate
powerpoint-präsentationen notizen wo ich
mein ganzes leben plane weil wenn ich
damit mein handy irgendwie was ein
kalendereintrag ich habe die ganze
gegner micro ich hab das nicht schlimm
aber wenn ich mein handy eine frage der
zeit automatisch mit icloud mit meinem
imac synchronisiert das eine super
geregelt also wenn ich dann in der
schule zum beispiel weiß auch ich
schreibt im mittelmeer zwei klausuren an
arbeit ist mein rechner hat mich dann
zwei wochen vor daran
und ja also deswegen dass ich habe also
zwei partitionen
er ist 27 zoll groß ich habe auch schon
mal ein video zu gemacht zu meinem
equipment das findet irgendwo auf einem
kanal das heißt mein equipment
jedenfalls als er hat nach ram krakau
und so weiter gefragt ich habe 16 gb ram
ich habe die nvidia geforce gtx 680 n
also nicht die echte 86
doch schon die echte aber nur die m also
die ich glaube es heißt mini oder mobile
ich weiß gar nicht das ist nämlich die
edition die eigentlich nur laptops
kommen weil der imac ist ein pc der halt
in einem ist also desktop pcs und da
könnt ihr halt nicht eine große
grafikkarte einbauen deswegen ist also
eine kleine laptop grafikkarte drin aber
sonst ja 16 gbyte ram nvidia geforce gtx
86 m
das ist einer wichtigsten pc oder i7
quad-core aber sonst wäre das das
wichtigste glaube ich wie sein wenn
kinder wieso habe ich ein wilder als
kind keine ahnung ich mag villiger
einfach ich habe den damals lahmenden
video emerald trading gesehen diesen und
ich fand
mega geil und ich habe auch schon ganze
zeit irgendwie immer nach seinem
villigers gesucht aber nicht an alle kag
und der sieht einfach geil das letzte am
anzug an und das repräsentiert mich
jetzt einfach wenn ich irgendwann mal
ein t shirt oder police machen werde
oder so dann wäre ich da auf jeden fall
also neben den motiven
eine ananas werde ich auf jeden fall so
gezeichnet man ihn wieder darauf machen
wenn ich mal irgendwann so was machen
soll wenn ihr das wollt werde ich mich
da vielleicht mal jemand daran setzen
dass das hinkriege und ich werde auf
jeden fall als machen wo ich so einen
richtig geilen gezeichneten villiger
kopf mit seinem anzug der hinkriege weil
ich hasse so t shirts war einfach da
draufsteht kontrakte wurden
wenn arial oder times new roman
schriften dann weiß auf schwarz unseren
scheiße deswegen ich möchte ein richtig
geiles die stadt deswegen einfach so ich
mag würde wenn nur ein thema in könntest
wenn ich jetzt mehr erste wahl welches
tier wäre ich denn gern ich glaube ich
wäre am liebsten sonnenwiese entweder
ein wiesel oder ein alpaka oder ein
koala das sind meine lieblingstiere
wiesel alpaka und koalas weiß nicht so
richtig ausgefallene tiere andere sagen
und köpfelte nasenbär ich weiß nicht ich
mag die tiere aber eigentlich würde ich
am allerliebsten mal ich wollte schon
mal ein pokémon sein sondern sich lohr
ich liebe dich du alter sicht was ich
geh jetzt man auch auf der straße
angesprochen hat youtuber und hast du
trotzdem noch dein normales schulleben
mir so auf der straße also komplett auf
der straße will ich auf der straße laufe
werde ich nicht angesprochen ein spaß
ich werd ich wurde angesprochen als ich
mal in köln war da wurde ich vier mal
angesprochen innenstadt natürlich
gamescom video day war heftig und was
mir auch immer ausfällt immer wenn ich
jetzt irgendwo feiern bin ich zehn immer
leute mir hat letztes hier dings
geschrieben warten werden wir dann
geschrieben büro mit dem ich zur
animation manchmal mache bis habe ich
ein mit ihm gemacht hat mir geschrieben
dass eine freundin von nämlich im go
parc gesehen hat in herford weil wir da
halt manchmal so bisher zelebranten sind
und sie hat sich nicht getraut mich
anzusprechen aber auch als setzen da war
habe ich drei leute im beim feiern
erkannt so hey bist du nicht mehr von
youtube ist soja hey was geht und noch
zwei nachher bei subway also das ist
irgendwie ganz interessant und wartet
was wachsen noch ob ich normale
schulleben habe ja also eigentlich habe
normales schulleben nur die die
kältesten ganzen sechsklässler und
siebtklässler dass die anhalt immer dich
gern den vorbei dann gucken sie alle
einfachen
dann bin ich halt zwei metern vorbei
dann hinterher gerufen das ist so ein
bisschen das nervt einfach aber muss man
mit leben
gehst auf eine einsame insel was nimmst
du etwas würde ich auf eine einsame
insel mitnehmen würde auf jeden fall
meine familie mitnehmen weil ich denke
dass ich früher oder später ihr heimweh
bekommen werde
ich würde meine besten freunde mitnehmen
wo ich sags mal so wenn ich drei sachen
mitnehmen dürfen einfach nur drei dinge
nicht so freunde nicht menschen und auch
keine tiere welche drei dinge mitnehmen
dürfen natürlich mitnehmen
mein handy handy ladekabel und was würde
ich noch mit nehme ich glaube ich wird
in der izone heißt er noch mit einem
ganz interessant das mittel was haben
deine momentan liebling youtube meinem
momentanen lieblings youtuber also ich
habe 150 leute oder so abonniert und ich
schaue keinen eigentlich ich sehe immer
nur was in der sub box ist und wenn ich
dann so sehe der ddr den getötet obwohl
das kommt nicht weil das den alimenten
wenn ich sehe und nicht mehr die
expert.de getötet dann gucke ich mir das
video mal an
oder wenn ich dann sehe dass da charlie
so cool lite nach zwei monaten mal
wieder ein video plan habe dann gucke
ich mir natürlich das an oder wenn keine
ahnung wenn bald die irgendwann
hochleben als neuen song paradiso dann
schaue ich da mal kurz rein aber
letztendlich habe ich gar nicht so viel
zeit dafür weil wenn ich immer schule
bis 5 uhr ab und danach noch training
und sport und blabla dann bin ich halt
zu hause dem dann selbst auf und flog
dann einfach nur eine folge dass das
alles einzige was zurzeit cookies
breaking bad keine youtube nur breaking
bad
wer jetzt ein mädchen wie würdest du
dich nennen wenn ich ein mädchen wäre
würde ich mich nennen
ich würde es ich finde den namen selena
richtig richtig geil also seid geil geil
geil ein komischer pädo holzdruck nein
ich bin damals trainer richtig schön
irgendwie also sowie geschrieben lena
gombert se also see und an lena ich
glaube ich wäre wenn ich ein kind
kriegen würde was denn wenn ich mädchen
kriegen würde sich das ziel in annen
finden am selena ihnen richtig geil
männlichen jungen kriegen würde würde
ich ihn finden denn weil ich sollte
damals eigentlich auch sein heißen aber
ich glaube da würde ich mein kind finden
weil ich finde ihn am finden und zu den
euro finde ich richtig geil finde ich
gut was hältst du von dsds fragezeichen
leerzeichen fragezeichen von dsds halte
ich nichts das ist so eine scheiße
diese ganzen leute die sind alle
engagiert von rtl geben
diese eine diesem elisa die da irgendwie
sonst bushido fan ist dann irgendwie
doch wieder kay one und aber ich habe
kein herz und oder dieser eine typ der
sich der stecher nennt ja da sagt ihr
euch für eure mädels im jahr so das sind
da das sind alles leute die einfach von
rtl engagiert sind das ist kein das ist
kein wesen nicht so es ist wirklich was
wo talente gesucht werden aber wenn dann
steht deutschland sucht den superstar
dann zeigen sie solche leute da im
fernsehen und andere die weiterkommen
zuvor gesehen könnte zeigen sie nicht
und weil sie nicht halte ich nichts von
erste fine art thomas fahr ich bin auto
ich fahre zur zeit gar kein auto
ich bin ja noch 17 ich fand immer die
autos von meiner mutter meinem vater
ich werde aber am 21 februar holt ist
der zwölfte das heißt wenn ihr
theoretisch 12 in den die 21 umdrehen
und oft im monat nur eins drauf zählt
dann habt ihr mein geburtstag hey nein
ich habe in sechs wochen geburtstag und
dann fahre ich ab dann auto alleine und
ich denke dann werde ich auch manchmal
so handy blogs machen und die auf luca
film dann wieder hochladen wenn jeder
bock drauf habe das wird an sondern
sonnen sondern wie lok kanal einfach wo
ich einfach so stumpf sachen hochladen
werde zu einfach was mir gefällt so
zweikanal mäßig halt also luca filmtagen
wird dann wieder was kommt
vollzeitbeschäftigter mit youtube nein
ich bin nicht vollzeit beschäftigt mit
youtube weil ich halt noch in die schule
gehe und weil ich halt noch 17
deswegen ist das ganze für mich zwar
schon sondern
hat job aber selten nebenjob das ganze
zu erklären ist jetzt ein bisschen
schwer weil ich halt auf eigene steuern
bezahlen muss ich bin in einer relativ
hohen steuerklasse und ich muss auch
meine ganzen versicherungen selbst
bezahlen und die kriegt kein kindergeld
mehr es ist alles vom staat geregelte
sachen halt ich werde es allerdings auch
nicht später als vollzeit ich packe die
ganze zeit mein mann stativ an das
irgendwie volker schneider m
ich werde das aber auch nicht später als
vollzeitbeschäftigung machen glaube ich
ich werde das ist glaube ich jetzt auf
gar keinen fall soweit machen ich denke
ich denke allgemein dass sich youtube
nur bis ende des studiums machen werde
jetzt macht er noch fünf jahre
aber ich muss halt schauen wie es das
alles hier weiterentwickelt weil ich zur
zeit echt immer weniger zeit haben für
youtube kann sein dass es nach dem abi
wieder besser wird meinte denen auch zu
mir dass es noch mal wie viel besser
wird dass man mehr zeit bekommt und ja
ich werde direkt nach der schule
anfangen zu studieren und danach dann
halten vernünftigen job ausüben und
denke nicht dass ich das ist mein leben
laufen lassen werde also natürlich
solange es mir spaß macht werde ich
machen aber die zeit muss auch immer
stimmen und zurzeit nicht vollzeit
beschäftigt mag oder eine königin und
mark vii kg ich hasse meine königin
jetzt die letzten folgen hero geguckt
wüsstest du dass auch aber morgen kommt
auch noch mal in folge wieder mal
bestätigt wird dass ich die königin
hasse und sie mich also diese königin
ist echt scheiße dies blöd ich will
nicht ich habe mich so eingesetzte sich
mein ganzes leben für sie aufgebaut hat
und sie hasst mich einfach machst du
nach denen der studiert hast du julia
class fragt was ich nach dem studieren
mache hat gesagt ich werde
wahrscheinlich irgendwann fliegen job
ausüben dann irgendwie marketing
management oder so das möchte ich
studieren marketing management in
hamburg wahrscheinlich ja die städte
ändern sich immer mal so ein bisschen
aber ich denke mit hamburg zu 99 prozent
hamburg wenn man einen apfelbaum mit
apfelsaft geht ist das deine zvunka
kannibalismus
florian die frage ist geil und
eigentlich ja es ist eigentlich
kannibalismus weil wenn man apfelbaum
mit apfelsaft dies der apfelsaft ist aus
dem apfelbaum als aus äpfeln gemacht die
vom apfelbaum sind eigentlich ist das
kannibalismus bestimmt richtig dutzend
oder kuscheln stopps so freunde das
war's mit dem heutigen tag eure
kommentare beantworten eure fragen
kommentiert blavius nennen wollte ich
weiß auch nicht wie es nennen werde wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann lasst auf
jeden fall einen daumen hoch da das ich
sehr ob ihr so was eventuell feiert
meine stimme wird gerade ein bisschen
kacke weil ich halt immer noch ein
bisschen heiser bin
nach abwägen habe ich auch mit dem hero
vorproduziert weil ich weiß dass ich
morgen ihr krank sein werde aber ich
würde sagen dass es beim nächsten
kontakt wieder schreibt mir die
kommentare aus dem nächsten kontakt
media und gut und leben